[Music]
okay so this is my review
of your honor episode 2. this episode is
directed by edward berger and written by
peter moffat
and remember peter moffat actually wrote
the show that the night
of was based off of criminal justice and
the reason i mention that here is
because
as this show keeps going on it reminds
you more and more of the pace of the
night of and the similar kind of story
here
and really delving into the aftermath
of something that happened significant
and how it affects all the parties
involved
so we actually opened this episode with
jimmy baxter played by michael stoolbarg
and he's listening to the 911 call that
adam had
made after he killed his kid so what's
set up well here from the top is that
jimmy baxter has his contact in the
police that's why he's able to get his
hands on this tape
this will also be the police officer
that goes in hard
to kofi later in this episode but what
it also shows now is there's this
crooked lieutenant on michael's side who
is through his
friend charlie who he's helped out move
up in politics he did him a huge favor
and we see charlie even says to michael
here he's like a brother to him so you
already have these two police officers
that are
both corrupt introducing this episode
and what party they're kind of helping
but what we really see
formed in this episode is the
relationship with michael and adam and
that
how they're gonna handle this problem
they're in now of
covering up this hit and run and we see
that michael
really turns on the full walter white
here he literally is just going into
deeper lies as this episode goes on so
similar to how ulta white would do it
where it's just a snowball effect
and you're almost cringing watching
because he has to talk his way out of so
many situations where he's almost
actually getting caught in particular i
love the scenes he has
with detective costello who we meet in
this episode played by
amy landecker who i love and everything
she's in
and she is not kim dickens they look
very similar but she really gives her
all here and plays really well off brian
cranston
they have such a great scene when she
actually finds the car
that he reports himself stolen to make
an alibi and it's this back and forth
where you're just
on your toes because she's seeing he's
on guard for some reason and off and he
even says him that's the first time
you've called me nancy and he's kind of
fumbling his words but talking out of it
but he's
going full in here like he's in full
emergency mode he's doing everything he
can to protect him and his son
he even has a line to adam here saying
you can do this or we
die not just adam both of us so he knows
the threat
of a guy like jimmy baxter we know the
threat of a guy like a jimmy baxter
i mean this guy by the end of this
episode smashes uh innocent bird to
death with a golf club
and he literally says he doesn't care
about anything anymore he's
completely in the deep end now after his
son died
he's a complete lunatic so clearly we
can believe
the character of michael when he says
this to adam but michael is so
meticulous i mean he's
literally setting up a full day's alibi
as if they relived yesterday with his
son going to this coffee shop
talking about the case he was working on
then brings his son to the grave and his
son is not
feeling this it's becoming in a sense
michael's biggest
obstacle is his own son adam in this
adam is the complete opposite of michael
here he's got a full conscience going on
he's not able to just whip this away in
emergency mode like michael is to
protect
themselves adam is just feeling guilty
and that's why it's so important
we get introduced now to this story and
character
of kofi kofi takes this job that was
started up by michael to charlie to his
quirky lieutenant
to this head gang member who gives it to
kofi a gang member in his own right but
what makes it so interesting with kofi's
story is that he
is the son of the woman that michael
just
cleared in court so he's going from this
family's hero and doing what he believes
is the right thing to
literally the opposite and that's why
it's so effective that
when he sees it's her mother in the
court at the end of this episode that's
really gonna hit michael
and it's also his courtroom that he has
all this justice in
and his beliefs and he sees this judge
humiliating someone
like a kofi kofi is clearly someone that
michael would defend
and try to get not guilty in a case like
this but now he's on the other side of
it
i do really appreciate too there's one
camera shot that really stood out to me
this episode is when
michael actually got the call that the
car
that he reported was actually caught
because he didn't want to get caught it
was supposed to get trashed
and you see there's this insanely high
overhead shot but
it's kind of showing you how small he
feels that moment in this huge mess he's
in
now just a loss of control but that
camera work is really effective in
showing us angles and where
michael is and where his head is at any
given moment there's also some important
lines with michael's character in
particular
one that stood out to me was when this
cop is driving
him home he brings up a case where he
let this guy
stealing underwear in the neighborhood
let go
because he says oh this guy eventually
ended up raping people but you see
michael's belief as a judge comes out
saying that you try
a case on the evidence not who you think
this man will become
and that's interesting to me because
that might be what ends up
biting them in the back if they have an
honorable judge on their case because if
we're gonna go
on the case of the baxter family in this
accident
if we're going evidence it's gotta
eventually lead to adam here
and that's exactly what michael doesn't
want to happen but it goes against that
moral code he has as a judge
but what is he as a man and that's what
we're learning and how
he's actually going against his grain as
a judge here so it's
interesting to this character because we
also meet this character of lee
played by carmony jogo was recently in
the latest season of true detective
but he's still in all this asked her to
a glass of wine
there's something mysterious about this
and there's got to be bigger reasons to
this
and kind of to me hints maybe there's
something
up here with what was going on with his
wife towards the end of her life
there's gotta be more mystery to this
backstory to that family of michaels
but he seems like he has a romantic
interest
in lee but by the end of this episode
we'll also see he's gonna need her
because he wants her to get
him access to talk to kofi but what they
did really well
kofi's character is the reason why he
would plead guilty
is because it's showing you that
he has to or basically he's being
threatened that
something might happen to his family and
it's sad and it makes you feel for kofi
this whole episode makes you feel for
coffee which is really effective because
then it really puts you
in adam's shoes and adam's predicament
because someone's already got a guilty
conscience as
adam does him seeing kofi in that
courtroom's really gonna set it off
and obviously he's gonna feel terrible
about this and that's why you get this
great shot where he's actually going
himself
to stand in the defendant's place really
just feeling out
the guilt he feels and that he knows he
should be in kofi shoes
but it's important they showed kofi's
character
with more layers than just him being a
piece to
move the plot where it needs to be it's
showing you
you feel for kofi the episode in the
sense of how he was brutally
basically tortured by baxter's crooked
cops here
and it shows you what baxter's capable
of
and what he would really be doing to
adam but it also shows you that
kofi is a story showing you what happens
to someone who's in a poor situation
how they end up in a gang and how
there's a no win for them
because he has to plead guilty just to
protect his family so he's
clearly just been screwed this whole way
so it adds an interesting third party to
this
story so for a second episode i still
think the show is pretty good
it's slow it's got that night of
defending jacob any kind of
crime story here but it has this teal
color palette it's cold
it's depressing it's that mood if you're
really into that this definitely feeds
that type of
target audience it does it well this was
a lot of setup here still
but it's only episode two there's a lot
of episodes to go i'm very intrigued by
this show so far
it's keeping me interested it's setting
up really good characters
and it's anchored obviously of course by
the brilliant brian cranston as the lead
which gives me even more hope for this
can go
i really do think this show has such
high upside
right now i'm gonna keep it though
around this range in the middle
of eight to nine so i'm gonna give this
one an 8.7
which i think is really good for setup
and i hope it just can stay interesting
the whole way i've said in my previous
review i'm a little worried that we
already know what happened at the crime
scene exactly so i hope they add enough
layers
to keep it interesting and some kind of
mystery and suspense for us to learn
stuff as this goes on that we didn't
know as the audience
but it looks like it's going that way
i'm hopeful in how this episode kind of
made the story a little more interesting
than even
from episode one let me know what you
thought this episode down below
i love to hear your thoughts i read
every comment and try to respond as many
as i can
please make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss one of my reviews of your
honor i'll be doing every episode
i can't stress enough how much it helps
me if you subscribe and if you want to
go the extra mile and you love what i do
i'd really appreciate if you can donate
to my monthly donation of two dollars
it's a paypal link in my description
that will help
me get to my dream of doing this full
time and make more videos for you guys
i would be truly grateful for it and
please follow me at steve barley show
on twitter instagram for more of me and
i'll see you next time